quick take last week we saw a historic
moment in sports where players from
almost
every major league in the u.s sat out
from games in protest of the police
shooting of jacob lake
to talk more about this and the wnba's
role in fighting for justice i'm joined
by
la sparks guard chelsea gray chelsea
thanks so much for joining me
thank you for having me chelsea so can
you bring me back to last week
what were the emotions like when you
guys all decided not to play
so we had gotten on the bus we weren't
the first game
um of that day so if the first game
didn't play it's not like we were going
to play in the second game
one thing that we stressed going into
this was that
you know it's solidarity whatever we
were going to do we were going to do it
all together and we got to the arena
washington and atlanta were already
discussing play or not play and we
wanted everybody's voice to be heard
and we made the decision not to play and
stand in solidarity
solidarity with the milwaukee bucks in
their decision not to play
um and i think it was an important one
especially to do it all together yeah
and like you said
all together you know this they started
the nba in the wnba
and you know you guys are never shy to
talk about these things and take a
stance
but then it trickled down into all these
other leagues across
sports what did it feel like to see that
and to have that unity from not just
basketball players but to have it
throughout the whole world of sports
yeah it was important um to be able to
see
all these different leagues and
different games you know really stand in
solidarity and understand you know
you know we hoop that's our profession
we play sports that's a profession but
we're human and it's a
human human issue going on humanity
issue going on right now
um it's a lot bigger than ourselves and
stepping outside of that and really
having those tough conversations
is was extremely important that's what
we were able to do on those days
and when you guys made a decision to not
play you still
had people make statements on the court
and have these conversations on the
court what kind of impact do you think
that has
other than just maybe giving out a tweet
before or after
it's important to be able to you know
for our youth to look up and look at the
tv and you see somebody that looks like
them our president
um the wnba president um neko glumakay
also my teammate
made a great statement understanding
that we're going to do it together and
it's her job to you know kind of voice
that
out and really have everybody on the
same page which we were
um but it's important to see those types
of people
you know black and brown women are used
to being you know
left behind and to be able to see ariel
atkins up there standing up saying
her piece neko gumma k elizabeth
williams up there stating
um different things it's it's it's vital
um to be able to have that and have
those open dialogues and actually say
how we feel
how we feel as a and you just said it
that
black and brown women are used to being
left behind and right now you're wearing
a shirt say
say her name um in stance with brianna
taylor can you talk more about
that and how you feel as a black woman
trying to stand up for other black women
in the world
um you know i think my teammate said it
best candice she was just like we're
you know with the wba we're majority of
a minority in the world world
right there's a lot of black and brown
women that's playing in this league but
you go outside of it and we're
definitely a minority we're black and
we're women
and then you add in that i am part of
the lgbtq plus community it's important
um that's a whole minority right there
um
even us standing there saying we're
we're doing that it's part of the
movement
it's it's part of the social justice
it's part of the change
and um you know we're used to you know
kind of being left behind
so we didn't care that we were standing
up saying what we believed
saying how we felt and um we have player
moms in here and we're doing that for
that little kid
so when they grow up they don't have to
deal with things like this
and you just started recently the
chelsea gray assist for equality program
can you tell me more about that and
why you felt the need to start it
i'm just trying to do my part and making
sure people are educated and understand
the importance of voting
so i'll partner with both equality
california and
rock the vote i'm donating fifty dollars
for every assist i dish out twenty five
dollars to equality california
and twenty five dollars to rock the vote
and um
the sparks have decided to match which
i'm excited about and i'm hopefully
going to get other organizations to
either match or donate
whatever the case may be but i wanted to
kind of
be in a relationship or have a
relationship with these companies
because it's important to educate people
on the importance of voting not even
at the presidential level right at the
local level the state level to
understand these different policies and
who they're voting for to push these
policies through
um so equality california is from
an organization that really tries to
push and help people of the lgbtq plus
community
and then rock the vote was with the
hooper's initiative to get these
athletes out there
to you know explain understand and
educate others of the importance of
voting at all levels
and why did you feel like personally
that you wanted to
go out there and talk about voting and
put your name on it
and tell them yeah just talking with my
peers being involved and educating
myself
outside of these circles has really
helped me to understand
and i knew you're you know growing up
you're supposed to vote for the
president
uh but beyond that it always seemed
complicated and difficult
um and now i'm i'm trying to be part of
that
you know that movement to be able to
educate people you know it's not it's
not that hard it's not that difficult
register to vote go somewhere to vote
sending your ballot whatever the case
may be according to your state
um but it's important every vote counts
absolutely every vote does count and
what do you think that it means to have
somebody like you and
other big name athletes like lebron
james and stuff have these um
movements and how impactful do you think
that can be
i think growing up you want to see on
you know on tv
in radios on now we got instagram and
twitter and things like that
um to be able to see somebody that looks
like them
that's not just an athlete but it's
going out there and you know trying to
strive for change
um using using your platform and
you know everybody has some sort of
platform
no matter how big or small but what you
do with it
is important you have people looking
that's that's going to be okay i
remember hearing this i remember hearing
that
um so now when you get in those times
that you can vote you pull somebody else
along and that's what we're trying to do
right
now and in the wmba you guys have
always been really at the forefront of
these issues and
using your platform like you said what
have you guys had more discussions about
what else else you're going to do to
take
steps forward and the next thing you can
do
to bring light to these issues i think
just
pushing the same initiatives that we've
been talking about
um actually having conversation with
people that
you know have had you know we had a
conversation with brianna taylor's
mother
and the importance of that you really
felt i like just have
just hearing her words it ate me up
and everybody has a cousin everybody has
an uncle
you know a relative that could have been
in their position
and so um i think right now we're in
discussion of you know how do we
how do we do something now and have a
plan of action that can really strive to
make change
and pushing people to vote the
importance of voting
um just keep pushing the initiative that
we're talking about and completing the
senses
and understanding the importance of that
and what
are the next steps that you would like
to see us as a country take
forward that proves that we're making
strides
in you know uh in towards racial
equality
and what is justice
um i would say just educating yourself
on the voting system
how it works what to win what to do to
ensure your vote counts
um why it's important you know actually
researching candidates
i know that i need to do more research
myself
and it's okay to do that it's okay to
educate yourself to make sure you're
making
the decision that you feel is right and
your vote is a way of having a voice in
this country
and um i just challenge people to do
that to go out and understand educate
themselves and help the next person
and um i think that's the way we strive
to make change
and uh just just uh have a have an
opportunity to be open to dialogue
and um have those uncomfortable
conversations
and that is like something that a lot of
people may not
be comfortable doing you know having
those uncomfortable conversations how do
people
start having those kinds of
conversations with maybe people who
aren't trying to listen
um you know that's a difficult question
but i would just say
you know find someone that is opening up
a little bit you all you need is a
sliver
you know you just need a little bit you
know you ask one question then it bleeds
to other things
um but challenge yourself um
if you come across somebody you know
relating to that person
you know open them up to you know see a
different point of view but that comes
with educating yourself
first and that's what i had to learn how
can i have these powerful
and conversations to be able to explain
my point of view without educating
myself
and i'm still doing that it's a forever
ending process
because you always want to get better
for the next person you learn something
you want to share with somebody else
um so educating yourself i feel like is
a huge thing
and uh keep planting those seeds for
future generations
absolutely chelsea thank you so much for
joining me
and for all you're doing for the fight
for equality thank you so much
thank you all for joining us and for
joining us in this conversation